[Music]
this is the true meaning of christmas
right here
give me
hey guys it's me jasmine i'm feeling
super festive today because we're gonna
be making cocoa buns you've probably
seen them all over your tik tok but if
you haven't they are these molded
chocolate balls filled with hot cocoa
toppings and we're gonna be making a few
variations of those today including one
for cider lovers can't forget you cider
lovers let's begin
i'm so excited
so the first cocoa bomb we're gonna do
is a white chocolate peppermint one
i have my white chocolate morsels and
we're gonna melt this down
[Music]
cook time
one minute
once that melts down we will brush it
into our silicone molds
you guys learned juggling in middle
school i remember that oh i didn't keep
a lookout for the time oh what's wrong
with me
all right let's give this a little mix
kind of smells like cheese this is the
first year i've purchased holiday
pajamas i feel like i've been missing
out my whole life now like i put these
on and i'm instantly so happy this looks
pretty good so we can begin to brush
these into the molds and then it'll give
it time to harden
i might need a pastry brush for this do
you think chocolatiers as kids they were
like i want to be a chocolatier when i
grow up why didn't we dream of that let
me switch to my pastry brush
this is so much better i pour too much
chocolate it's not dispersing evenly
because we need to melt down the edges
in a bit let's just get rid of this
excess chocolate you need to clean it
when the chocolate's hot otherwise it
will crack oh no they cracked i should
have done it oh this is where i'm
messing up okay my confidence has
definitely just continued to
decrease but i'm optimistic because i've
got the holiday spirit i'm gonna pop
this in the fridge
no there's no space this is why you
don't go to the grocery store hungry
there's no space in your fridge after
that and now we're gonna take them out
of the molds i see people using gloves
to avoid fingerprints so that's what i'm
gonna do too
oh
we got our first one
pretty smooth
it cracked
oh my god
i'm going to start it off with some hot
cocoa powder little truffle
inception or marshmallows and of course
you can't forget your pretty sprinkles
oh my god so cute so now we're going to
decorate the tops i have my red candy
melt no
now i'm gonna do with the chocolate
which seems to have melted
no it's not working
it's definitely not as cute as i want it
to be but because it's still wet i'm
gonna sprinkle some crushed peppermint
cute
both the bottom and the tops of the
cocoa bomb are done so i've heated up a
pan over here so we're gonna melt down
those bottoms not too long not too long
put it on
gotta work quickly oh look at that oh my
god
forgot to wear gloves there's
fingerprints on this look how cute it is
oh my goodness
now that all our cocoa bombs are
complete we can go ahead and drink them
so we're going to grab our mug put a
cocoa bomb inside and slowly pour over
hot milk
baby come here
oh my god
oh that's crazy
oh my god
beautiful
that looks so good stir it with my candy
cane oh my god i want to try that looks
so good oh my god it's so cool the last
step whipped cream
and let's not be afraid for some extra
sprinkles
oh that's so cool
oh my god that is so good
oh i want more it's so chocolaty
slightly peppermint
that is really good that's a bang okay
let's move on to the next one
this one is the butterscotch cocoa bomb
for our cider i know some people don't
love hot chocolate uh but to each their
own and some people prefer cider so i
have some melted butterscotch right here
make the outsides again
my butterscotch is grainy which i think
means i burnt it that just continues my
streak of messing up melting chocolate
so i'm going to try letting it set by
layers so i'll do this first one and
then pop it in the fridge and let this
set and do one more layer
so i did the second layer and let it set
again seems pretty good and a lot faster
than just pouring it and kind of pushing
it up along the sides in one take so i
recommend doing it in layers let's hope
none of these are
i also already cleaned out the sides
[Music]
[Music]
okay i'll fix that we have the three
bottoms let's add our toppings for this
one i'm going a little fruitier i feel
like it goes with the vibe more these
are some dried pomegranates
after the pomegranate gotta add some dry
apples and finally just gonna add some
white chocolate chips i was gonna add
the glitter in there again but because
it sunk in the last one learning from
our mistakes and we're not gonna add
them in this time we'll just put on top
of the whipped cream let's go add the
tops i am going to do a white chocolate
drizzle and top it with those pretty
fall sprinkles
yay look how festive this is i'm
obsessed with this i'm not going to lie
when i first saw a coco bomb tik tok i
was like that's right that's cool look
at me now
this is like so fun as a craft activity
and then you get to drink it and eat it
afterwards and it's sugar and it makes
you happy i'll take any happiness i can
get this here
now we just got to put the tops on the
cocoa bombs oh my god this one's way
meltier i need my gloves this one feels
so fragile
it's sticking
[Music]
apply pressure apply pressure okay i was
scared for a second it was melting at
like
super speed okay
oh my god look how pretty they are
my cocoa bomb babies i love them welcome
to the family my friends now that the
cocoa bombs are put together it's time
to make these guys explode i brought my
boyfriend back for another coco bomb
experience he seemed to really enjoy the
first one so
this one is the butterscotch cocoa bomb
for cider oh that sounds really good all
right baby ready for this cider bomb
heck yeah we're gonna put the
butterscotch bottle over there into the
mug oh it's so pretty i don't even want
to ruin it the magic begins
wow that looks so festive dang
this is the true meaning of christmas
right here
so cute
beautiful what is it dried apples dried
pomegranate and then there's a few
uh white chocolate morsels in there and
then i have a cinnamon stick
we're gonna stir it of course whipped
cream
and the fall glitter oh wow
okay i'm gonna sip it from the table
first
that's so cool
oh
man that's like an apple pie but in
liquid form oh yeah yeah
yeah isn't this so good i didn't believe
in the dried apples but that's so good
kimmy
this is bomb huh that's good no pun
intended i feel like this should be on
our holiday menu
who isn't this going to impress on to
the next one last but certainly not
least if not probably the most we have
the new year's themed cocoa bomb what am
i doing with my hands i don't know i
have super
dark chocolate here i've already melted
it brush it up along the sides for the
next three i'm going to start sprinkling
in my edible gold stars in and it'll
have it as the top this one needs to be
very sparkly because when i think of new
year's i think of going all out all
right now i'm gonna drizzle this
chocolate over the stars so now that i
have some chocolate in there i'm gonna
slowly brush it up
careful to not pick up any of the stars
but more like just brush the chocolate
over them hopefully we still see some
stars after it sets also forest comes to
worse we could just redecorate it no
problemo i took out all the chocolates
from the mold the tops came out
beautifully i'm very pleased with them
now we're just gonna go ahead and build
these cocoa bombs i have dark chocolate
hot cocoa powder here and i was gonna
have different sprinkles for the inside
but someone stole them off my front
porch if you stole my sprinkles off my
front porch you're on the naughty list
i'm gonna add these gold star sprinkles
from earlier i'm gonna add some
marshmallows now we're going hard here
chocolate liqueurs for one of them i
will do a fancy macaron cute
wow this is so fancy
[Music]
we lost one it melted while i was
setting up the camera and now we'll
never know its true potential
oh god
it's cracking ah
we did it we got it it is on two lovely
cocoa bombs are completed ripped to our
friend that didn't make it babe one more
cocoa bomb he ran down very quickly he's
very excited for this last super excited
okay ready you don't even know what's in
here yet oh oh my god oh no you can't
see ah
oh my i thought it was a huge
marshmallow is that a macaron it's a
macaroon
i'm gonna mix it up real quick oh i'm
seeing a lot of chocolate in there you
know what this is probably gonna melt
is it hot is it good yeah that's so good
of course whipped cream
let's add a few more glittery stars and
of course we need
oh wow that is gorgeous
shall we try
yes
yellow sun
you wanna try
oh that's so good really warm the soul
okay why don't you just take that over
there you can enjoy that careful okay
stripy all right guys i would call that
a success overall i feel like we made
three beautiful cocoa bombs i totally
see the hype around cocoa bombs now
they're just so pretty and it's fun to
make of the ones we made today i would
say that the butterscotch cider one was
my favorite it was just super unique
just made me love cider even more let me
know in the comments below what food i
should make next and if you end up
making any cocoa bombs make sure to tag
me on instagram happy holidays bye
[Music]
why
what are you saying
hey it's betsy i'm jasmine i'm katie
today i will be competing against my
co-workers to see who can create the
best original dish using thanksgiving
leftovers in under 60 minutes the
leftovers include turkey mashed potatoes
gravy cranberry sauce stuffing roasted
vegetables green beans and pumpkin pie
we're also allowed to add whatever
additional ingredients we want and then
our co-worker kelly will judge our
dishes based on how many of the
leftovers we use if we finish within the
60 minute time frame our dishes
presentation
and finally taste i'm definitely very
nervous you know i'm a very competitive
person i have a lot of competitive
energy but my confidence level is low i
feel like i have a delicious plan but i
i'm scared of betsy and jasmine for sure
they're fierce competitors
today i am going to be making a
thanksgiving leftovers charcuterie board
i'm gonna have four homemade components
a pumpkin pie truffle prosciutto wrapped
stuffing bites a roasted veggie dip then
some crostinis with some smoked salmon
topped with some fancy piped mashed
potatoes garnished with a little bit of
fresh dill i can get that done in 16
minutes right three
two one
go
i'm gonna start by making pumpkin pie
truffles first things first we are going
to put this slice of pumpkin pie into
this dish here and we're gonna mash it
up with a fork okay that looks good i'm
gonna loosely start to create some balls
i love dessert so i knew that i had to
have at least one sweet thing on the
platter
i'm moving on to our prosciutto wrapped
stuffing bites i am now gonna take our
leftover stuffing and form it into more
balls next i'm going to take our
beautiful prosciutto and wrap it around
the outside trying to make this look as
graceful as possible which is why we
have toothpicks to kind of help secure
it on there wow that looks good i'm
intimidated i think i'm more intimidated
by katie and jasmine than i am kelly
please be good
we are now gonna move on to our roasted
veggie dip we're gonna place our roasted
veggies into a food processor along with
some cream cheese because cream cheese
makes everything better and now i'm
gonna add in two garlic cloves
i'm gonna scrape down the sides here a
little bit a little pepper
and a little salt and i'm also gonna add
in a little bit of olive oil to loosen
it up a little bit
oh there we go
we're getting there
it does smell good but does a good smell
mean good taste
it could use some onion or some chives
so i'll put in a few
our dip is done you have 40 minutes
remaining oh okay so i've got some
crackers here i'm now going to top them
off with some smoked salmon so this
smoked salmon is very thick i feel like
it's very hard for me to like make it
look pretty but fear not we are going to
actually top the smoked salmon with our
mashed potatoes i'm going to transfer
our mashed potatoes to a piping bag
fitted with a piping tip and we're going
to pipe them on top oh gosh it's like
spaghetti
i don't have a plan b
oh gosh i now have a new piping tip that
is a slightly more open here we go
[Music]
a little better for sure
that's fine
come on like there's pieces of potato
getting stuck in the piping tip
i think i'm gonna need a plan c
plan c
same piping tip this time however we
added some milk to our mashed potatoes
to help loosen them up a little bit all
right let's give it a go let's give it a
go okay guys this is
much better a little runny but i'll take
it we did it now i'm gonna place some
fresh dill on top and voila our smoked
salmon mashed potato crackers are
finished
we are on our last step we are going to
now coat our pumpkin pie pops into some
melted dark chocolate i also have some
freshly ground graham crackers to top
them off
our chocolate pumpkin pie pops are done
one of the reasons why i chose a
charcuterie board is because you kind of
go through all of these steps to make a
thanksgiving feast so i really wanted to
kind of deconstruct that and make it
kind of easier approachable and
shareable so by looking at my
charcuterie board i think i've included
every single thanksgiving leftover we
have our roasted veggies our mashed
potatoes green beans cranberry sauce
turkey stuffing pumpkin pie and we even
have our gravy one thing's for sure this
charcuterie board has something for
everyone all right i'm done you have one
minute and 31 seconds oh
yes
yeah
i'm going to use all the ingredients to
make a croquette flight i'll start with
the vegetable appetizer croquette move
to the turkey entree croquette and then
finally a dessert croquette with the
pumpkin pie i went with the croquette
flight because i'm also a producer on
bring me and our biggest hits are always
the flights never made a curl cap before
so we're off to a great start your time
starts
now ah okay okay okay start with some
oil got some chopped green beans gonna
go ahead and throw the roasted
vegetables in there as well and i'm
adding these onions i'm just gonna
stir-fry these vegetables for a little
bit until they're heated through all
right they're almost heated through so
i'm gonna sprinkle a bit of garlic salt
don't want kelly eating anything
unseasoned some pepper
oh i'm still shaking i'm nervous you
know the feeling of when you make
something very special and then you give
it to someone and they don't like it
there's always that paranoia
okay this looks pretty good i'm gonna
turn off the heat we're gonna transfer
these to our bowl with mashed potatoes
which are leftovers mix that up for the
sake of more flavor i'm just gonna add a
splash of gravy it's so chunky this
looks good so i'm going to move on to
dredging i'm flowering my hands to
prevent it from sticking so i can roll
this into a nice ball shape or a
flattened oval
dip it in the flour
no why did i do that i should have made
the wet batter first okay i'm so dumb so
i'm gonna add about like a tablespoon of
cupid yes cupid is superior it is a
little sweeter a little tangier i'm
gonna add some water
let's dip that in there
you said presentation matters huh asking
for a friend asking for katie
okay so now that it is in this flat oval
shape i'm gonna put it into the airfryer
and then i'm going to spray it
okay that's going to go for 8 minutes so
while that's going we can make our next
croquette
why what are you saying
okay we have a working airfryer now
i'm gonna let that go for eight minutes
and i'll flip it halfway through but for
now let's move on to the entree turkey
croquette i have some olive oil heated
up here and we're going to start by
caramelizing our onions how much time do
i got left you have 40 minutes i think
we're on a good track i'm probably going
to let them caramelize until they're
just before medium brown okay not bad
i'm just going to stop caramelizing now
i'm gonna remove the extra oil you know
what fried onions are delicious so this
is this will be a treat so i'm gonna mix
stuffing
it's extremely dry just a little bit of
gravy
some garlic salt and some black pepper
i got the mashed potato mixture that i
made from earlier just gonna add it in
here because it is extremely dry and it
needs to hold together okay this looks
good let's get to dredging
throw it into the airfryer and move on
to the next one we have 20 minutes oh we
got one okay we gotta move on to the
next one like now okay we're on our last
croquette i'm doing the dessert
croquette using pumpkin pie i'm gonna
first carve out some filling the crust
on the bottom is too wet so i am going
to take the side of the crust and
crumble it in here this doesn't look
like enough so i might have to use the
wet crust anyway all right i'm just
going to throw it all in it all tastes
the same in the end you know okay it's
getting to the point in the competition
where i'm like i have so little time and
i need to do everything 10 minutes ago
that that doesn't look like enough
i'm just gonna throw a little more in i
have used the pumpkin pie leftovers
let's add in the marshmallows just gonna
fold that together when it's really wet
it doesn't hold its shape so i'm going
to add some cornstarch as a thickener
i'm going to add a little bit more
marshmallows i need it to stay together
while it's cooking because if it melts
all together into the airfryer i'm out
okay i'm going gonna add the granola
oh it's kind of thick all right whatever
we don't have time to crush it so let's
get to dredging we're not gonna use the
same egg as last time because i had mayo
gonna add a splash of milk though
okay that looks good 15 minutes ah
so much pressure this is a pretty good
shape i'm actually really surprised it's
holding it together
oh my gosh
these granolas are humongous the pie
crust is sticking much better than the
granola but i actually think this might
work okay the one thing is now the size
is much bigger than the other croquettes
but a big dessert is good i think and
everyone has a second stomach for
dessert
okay eight minutes on the clock i'm
shaking my clock is running down but
when that comes out we're just gonna go
ahead and plate it everything is plated
and
i'm done you have five minutes and 21
seconds left yes okay finish in time i
used all the ingredients and i finished
within 60 minutes it's hard to say how
confident i am because i haven't seen
betsy and katie's dish but i would say
i'm walking out feeling better than i
did walking in i think it looks pretty
decent but now it's up to kelly to
decide whether or not she likes it and
if it looks good enough
so here's my plan i'm going to be using
everything but the green beans to make a
delicious trio of raviolis i'm not using
green beans because i don't like them
and i forgot that they were there so
they didn't they weren't in my plan your
time starts now okay
okay so right now i'm going to be making
my ravioli dough first and this is just
some double o flour so i'm going to add
my eggs into my well of flour and then
i'm going to add a little bit of olive
oil and then i'll just take a fork and
beat these eggs in the center and we
don't want our well to break and my
walls broke my walls broke and it's fine
you know this happens i'm just going to
kind of gently pull this in on itself
here so i'm going to bring this now
together with my hands and then i am
going to let the machine do the work for
me because i have too much stuff to do
so i'm going to put this in my mixer
with a dough hook all right i'm going to
let this go for five minutes or at least
till it's nice and smooth and when you
press the dough it springs back
just gonna walk away
all right our dough looks done so i'm
just gonna wrap this in plastic wrap and
i'm gonna let this rest for about 20 to
25 minutes while i make the fillings so
my first filling is kind of like the
whole shebang a little bit i'm gonna add
some of that leftover turkey that's i've
shredded it so that it's gonna combine
really nicely and you get a little
turkey in every bite i'm gonna add some
cranberry which could be a mistake i've
never tried this before but i think the
tartness is going to go really well in
here and then i'm going to add some
fresh thyme i will do a little bit of
gruyere cheese i'm going to add one egg
this is going to help bind all of this
together and then i'm just gonna start
mixing this together i don't know dare i
add more cranberry is kelly does kelly
hate cranberry i'm gonna bank on she
loves it and we're just gonna add a
little bit more
okay my turkey stuffing filling is done
and i am going to move on to my cheesy
potato filling this next filling i'm
kind of basing off like a pierogi
filling usually like a cheese potato
filling so that's what i'm trying to go
for here i'm going to add a little bit
of gravy because like you know mashed
potatoes and gravy so i'm going to add
in some parmesan because i like a
sharper cheese and then some cheddar
which is just kind of my classic cheesy
potato
oh i like it
i'm going to add a little pepper
all right these are looking nice some
smooth mashed potatoes so these are done
i'm gonna move on to my last one which
is a sweet filling this next filling is
a pumpkin filling with some roasted
veggies what i'm gonna do is take some
of our leftover pumpkin pie i'm just
gonna use the filling we're gonna put
this into a food processor so i'm gonna
try to dull that sweetness by adding
some of these roasted carrots and sweet
potatoes and then i'm gonna add some
goat cheese it'll help bind this
together and kind of cut through all
that sweetness and then i'm going to add
in some fresh
nutmeg because it just smells like the
holidays and it just has a lot of flavor
and then we'll add a little bit of salt
and some
pepper and i'm just going to add a
little bit of olive oil to help loosen
it up
i'm going to actually add a little bit
of water the olive oil doesn't seem to
be enough and i don't want to like alter
the taste too much
that's looking good it smells like
pumpkin pie but let's see
if it still tastes like pumpkin pie
i think that's good all right well i
think i'm done with my filling so now i
just have to assemble my raviolis how
much time do i have left you have 32
minutes left we got to get going we got
to go so i have my ravioli dough here i
am going to cut this guy into quarters i
don't want to be working with too much
dough at once for the guys i'm not using
right now i'm going to cover in plastic
so they don't dry out i probably don't
need all that dough but i made backup
because you know mistakes so for this
first section of dough i'm just gonna
flatten it out i'm not gonna put any
flour on this dough because it's pretty
dry dough already i will have her
sprinkle a little onto my pasta roller
and we'll get it going and we're just
gonna put our pasta through this machine
and then i'm gonna fold it like that and
it helps get a nice shape to it and
we're gonna run it through a few times
and you can just see it's getting longer
and longer every time we do it we're
going to stop there
and i am going to put some plastic over
that guy so it doesn't dry out i'm going
to repeat those steps one more time all
right i'm going to quickly assemble my
ravioli so i have my second sheet here
and i'm going to gently brush that with
water i don't want to get it soaking or
anything like that but this is going to
help us seal it later usually you'd make
a small ravioli and you fold this in
half but i'm making giant ones so first
i'll put on my pumpkin pie filling
next i'm gonna put down some stuffing
and last i'm gonna add my cheesy potato
okay so before my
water dries i'm gonna place this
other sheet of pasta over it you want to
squeeze all around the base of your
ravioli trying to get out that air
because if you leave air it has a chance
of opening up while it's cooking and you
don't want that i'm going to cut this
middle guy out first so i'm going to use
a pasta cutter and i am gonna do
a square for him 20 minute warning okay
20 minutes that's fine that's fine the
sauce is gonna be fast let's do a
triangle for this guy which i'm just
gonna go for it and then for our last
one feels like it's like grade school or
something because there's all these
really silly shapes great huge i'm gonna
go get some boiling water and we're
gonna make our sauce and we're almost
ready for plating so i've got my
raviolis cooking and boiling water
that's gonna happen real fast so i'm
gonna start to make our sauce i'm gonna
do a brown butter sage sauce i'm gonna
cut the butter up into pieces this way
our butter just cooks more evenly so you
wanna be constantly stirring the butter
and you can't really not pay attention
because it can go from being brown to
burned very quickly so while this is
going i'm gonna add in some walnuts for
texture and flavor and then i'm gonna
add some sage and these are all gonna
toast and fry in the butter and just
give us deliciousness all right so i'm
adding some salt you can smell that sage
and now you can see we're getting those
brown bits when you drag the spoon you
can kind of see those in there
all right our pasta is ready to go
none of them broke apart so that's good
and a little pasta water in this is okay
these are giant i think i should do
making it big with alvin these are so
good
we're just gonna toss these in the sauce
gently just wanna coat that and now
we're gonna plate these guys
ten minute warning okay if i can't plate
this in ten minutes i should be fired
and then i'm just gonna pour
some of these sauce over the top here
i'm gonna add a little bit of crushed
pepper on top and
some parmesan stop the time all right
you finished your dish with seven
minutes and 34 seconds
do i win i used all but one ingredient i
think it actually looks pretty great and
now the only thing left to do is have
kelly judge it hopefully not harshly
hey i'm kelly and i'm the lead culinary
producer here at tasty and i'm going to
judge each of these three dishes before
i try anything we have a few points to
calculate so based off the number of
leftovers they used betsy gets a seven
out of seven jasmine gets a seven out of
seven and katie gets a 6.5 out of seven
because she forgot about the green beans
so since they all finish cooking within
the 60 minutes they'll each get three
more points so now for presentation on a
scale of one to three i'm going to give
betsy a three because this is insane
jasmine a two and kadia three there's
nothing wrong with jasmine's but i just
think katie and betsy really blew it out
of the park jasmine's is beautiful but i
think it could have been displayed a
little bit different so last up is the
taste test the most important part i'm
gonna be ranking them one out of three
three being my favorite
so betsy's i just think it is so
beautiful i can't wait to try everything
she did a really good job visually
i know bessie was worried about that dip
but it is incredible
all right let's try jasmine's so a
little secret i hate cranberry sauce
it's my least favorite part of
thanksgiving
wow you can see the marshmallow like
melting in there
it tastes incredible this was a really
ingenious idea this is the cheese and
potato one
all right this is the turkey one that
she put extra cranberry sauce in so
let's see
the cranberry sauce actually balances
out the saltiness of the rest of the
dish it's really good
now that i've tried all three i think i
know which one's my favorite so let's go
tell them all right ladies you did a
great job everything tasted amazing but
there can only be one winner
the winner is
[Music]
katie
i loved yours because i felt like you
took it a step further you browned
butter you made the sage super crispy
and you made pasta like i wouldn't have
even tried to attempt that in 60 minutes
i was a little skeptical about that
cranberry sauce wait do you not like
cranberry i hate cranberry
but it actually went really well
together i'm so excited i won i never
win anything but this is so much fun
thank you guys for doing this with me
and thank you kelly for being our judge
let us know if there's any other
leftover challenges you guys want us to
try and until next time bye guys bye
[Music]
okay is that too big of a slice no hey
guys it's me jasmine and today i'm gonna
be challenged to recreate a vacation
through food i've been receiving letters
from people who've had to cancel their
vacations because of kovid so i am going
to help them live out their vacation
through an authentic recipe given to me
by a local so they can at least go on a
taste bud trip the first postcard comes
from tiffany who had to cancel her trip
to greece dear jasmine i was supposed to
go to greece this summer for a wedding i
was really looking forward to eating all
the authentic greek food my body could
handle and i absolutely love desserts
can you show me how to make an authentic
greek dessert yes i can greek cuisine
often uses oregano dill
mint bay leaves and a few others but i
want tiffany to have the most authentic
taste bud trip possible so i am
enlisting the help of greek local madam
ginger who knows the ins and outs of
greek cuisine hey jasmine madame ginger
here and i'm really really happy to help
so everyone thinks that in greece we
only eat souvlaki or muzaka yes we do
eat those and we really love them but
every local would know how special and
traditional orange philo pie is in
greece we call it porto callo that's why
today i'm giving you my recipe for this
delicious greek dessert you really
really need to try it i've never made
orange pie before i've never even heard
of it and i think i've got my work cut
out for me today let's do this so one of
the star ingredients in this cake is
phyllo dough so using our hands we're
just gonna rip our filo dough into
uneven pieces but it's gonna be
important that we separate the layers
because we don't want them to dry in
chunks it could be as uneven as you like
because we're gonna crush them up anyway
so no big deal i do this when it's still
frozen so it's easier to work with once
it starts to defrost you can get some
extra moisture in there which makes it
harder to work with you just want to
fluff them up because you don't want
them to stick together make sure to
aerate them pretty nicely and don't
forget to separate the layers this is
kind of therapeutic i am quite enjoying
this so once you've stripped them into
these uneven pieces go ahead and aerate
them again and spread them out evenly
onto the pan once you have something
that looks like this we're gonna bake
them in the oven for about 20 minutes
until they're lightly toasted and
hardened so the next step is to whip the
eggs and sugar together until they're
light colored and fluffy i feel like
recipes are sometimes so specific yet
oddly so big like what does light colors
mean what does fluffy mean is that soft
or is that thick i'm not really sure so
we're gonna give kelly a call kelly is
our wonderful culinary developer on
tasty and she's gonna give us a quick
egg whipping 101 hey kelly hi jasmine i
need some help okay i was wondering if
you could give us a quick egg whipping
101 i am looking at the recipe and it
says to whip the eggs until they're
light and fluffy what does that mean are
there do's and don'ts what should i be
looking for first off are your eggs room
temperature yes okay perfect what you
want to do is put your eggs and sugar in
a bowl and whip them with a hand mixer
or a stand mixer over a medium high
speed until they've like doubled or
tripled in volume their color will
change from like a darker yellow to a
pale yellow color and they'll be thick
like not like a mayonnaise but maybe
like in between a sour cream and a
mayonnaise consistency don't over whip
it because then you can't go back and
also you'll know it's done when you pick
up your whisk and some of it falls down
and if it sits on top of the other
batter in the bowl and creates ribbons
that's when you know it looks perfect
okay got it thank you so much you're a
lifesaver you're welcome i can't wait to
see the finished product bye
now that we've gotten our lesson from
kelly i feel pretty prepared got our
room temp eggs here gonna add them all
in and now we're gonna whip them until
they're light and fluffy so after about
five minutes of mixing we now have these
gorgeous ribbons that don't sink in
immediately and now we're gonna add in
our sunflower oil baking powder vanilla
extract so for the zest you only want
this outer layer of the orange the white
spongy part in the middle over here that
is called the pip and that's very bitter
so if you start zesting the pith and
including it in the cake you might get
some bitterness to it so the zest we're
adding in is from unwaxed oranges and
what unwaxed oranges means is organic
and then we're going to add in our full
fat greek yogurt
i'm going to mix this in a little bit
before we use our mixture again to mix
it up until it's nice and smooth we're
going to grab our phyllo dough that we
dehydrated earlier and we're just gonna
crush it up into small pieces
and then fold it into our mixture i am
taking my greased baking dish and i'm
just going to
add it in there oh my god it smells like
butter orange and vanilla oh my goodness
i'm so excited to try this i'm just
gonna spread it so that it's nice and
even in the baking dish
it smells heavenly i'm so excited to put
this in my body
okay into the oven it goes so while the
orange pie is baking in the oven let's
go ahead and make our syrup we're just
gonna add in our orange juice
freshly squeezed our water juice from
one lemon an orange peel and our sugar
let's give that a good stir
and we're just gonna let this simmer for
about 10 or 12 minutes until the sugar
dissolves and the syrup thickens the
orange pie is finished so we're gonna
poke these holes into the pie so that it
can absorb the syrup when we pour it in
afterwards so after you've poked your
holes into the orange pie we're gonna
slowly ladle our syrup over the cake
until it slowly and fully absorbs all of
it i've let the pie cool for about an
hour still warm and that's why i want to
cut it now because i do still want it
when it's nice and fresh you can see
that it already absorbed all the syrup
okay is that too big of a slice no oh my
gosh it looks so moist sorry if you hate
that word
look at that oh my goodness let's try it
cheers that might be one of my most
favorite things i've ever made that is
so good the zest that we added makes the
pie taste so fresh the phyllo dough
inside is so good it's almost custardy
and you can actually feel the phyllo
dough inside and it adds different
layers within the pie to create a
different texture this is so good
tiffany you're going to be so happy
[Music]
hey guys it's jasmine and today i'm
going to be showing you guys how to make
the cutest little animal bells i have a
bunch of different designs for you and a
variety of fillings both sweet and
savory so you can mix and match your
favorites let's get started this one is
the pig bow with the chocolate truffle
filling and we're going to start by
making our dough we're just going to
throw everything in our milk our yeast
sugar and flour i'm using all-purpose
flour here but if you have bread flour
that's even better before we use the
dough hook to mix it up i like to first
combine it together once you get a solid
dough that looks sort of like this we
can go ahead and grab our stand mixer
i'm attaching my dough hook and i'm
going to turn it to a medium high speed
after 10 minutes the dough should look
like this you just take it off your
dough hook should be nice and soft and
uh baby butt smooth and uninterrupted
like this let's go ahead and place it
back into the mixing bowl cover it with
a wet towel we're just gonna let it sit
for an hour
i have my dough here just gonna pick a
small part of it off about two
tablespoons of dough ish gonna roll it
into a ball and then into a log hold the
outer end inwards like this and then
roll it out again and we're gonna repeat
that two or three times and you'll
notice that it gets even smoother than
it was before and it was already pretty
freaking smooth and then the last time
we can just start rolling it into a wall
and once you do this for a little bit
you'll get like this ultra smooth ball i
like to press it down onto my palms it
doesn't need to be like a perfect circle
quite yet put the
not pretty side up we have a chocolate
truffle and we're just gonna
press it in you're just gonna let the
motion take you and then you're gonna
pinch it closed and then you can see
that it's like not very pretty over here
so we're just going to roll it again and
then make sure your nails aren't facing
into the ball because then you can
scratch it this does require some
patience so if you feel like you make it
and it's really ugly happened to me too
but it doesn't matter it's all about
having fun in the kitchen
time for the fun part it's time to
decorate our pig and let's make its
features i'm adding a little bit of pink
food dye to a small piece of dough if
you don't want to use food dye you can
use other natural substitutes like beet
juice beet extract hibiscus powder i use
the same method for getting the food dye
incorporated just continuously rolling
it into a log and folding the outer ends
in and it should look something like
this i'm going to pull off a little more
dough this is just for the pig's eyes so
we want to put a little bit of a black
food coloring on it again we're just
going to roll it until it's nice and
uniform in color so now we can really
get to work i like to decorate my bells
one at a time if you make all the
features beforehand you increase the
chances of all the little features
drying out and it makes it hard to stick
and then they can crack while steaming
so i suggest doing it one by one before
i start creating all the features i like
to apply a little bit of water onto the
surface of the bow where i'll be
sticking the features on
two black dots for the eyes you can make
all your features different than i am
design it how you'd like and make it
your own have fun with this once you
have all its features on it you can take
a chopstick and i like to poke a hole
directly into the nose you might have to
do this a couple times because sometimes
the dough does bounce back depending on
what kind of flour you're using
especially common with all purpose and
for the ears because pig ears do fold in
a little bit i take the chopstick and i
just press it in like this and then i
squeeze it together and you got a little
piggy
the piggy buns have been resting for
about 30 minutes now and i'm really
excited to steam them i don't have a
bamboo steamer so just go into your
kitchen find the biggest pot you can
find and then you're gonna put a bowl in
the bottom add some water to the bowl
for weight and then water to the pot so
now you can put your plate on top of the
bowl and then we're just going to place
our little baby piggy buns
into the pot don't put them too close to
each other because they do tend to
expand and spread out into like an oval
shape and let's get to steaming just
gonna put it on medium heat and steam it
for about nine minutes if you're worried
about water droplets from the lid
dripping onto your buns you can put a
towel in between the lid and the pot and
fold the corners onto the top of the lid
i personally haven't had an issue with
the water droplets so i don't need to do
that today they're looking so cute and
i'm so excited to see them they're so
cute
how can we eat these
starting dripping everywhere it looks so
chocolatey cheers
mmm
i mean if you like chocolate
i think you're in for a good treat
so if you don't want to add any fillings
to your buns this is where you would
stop you have this perfectly round dough
baby here and you can begin to
decorate your panda but if you want to
add the filling we are doing red bean
for the panda so from here you'll have
this round ball let's just press it down
like this add a spoonful of red bean the
red bean paste is quite thick especially
after you refrigerate it and then we can
put it in there just like we did with
the truffle and seal it up going to wet
the surface of the bow again we're about
ready to decorate so let's put our
little dough baby onto the parchment
square and now for the panda features
we're going to make two large ears with
the black dough
two black ovals for the eye patches and
of course the adorable little pandanos
and there's your finished panda so i'm
gonna let these rest again for 30
minutes and then we can pop them into
the steamer and before you know it
they're going to be done
look at that
it looks so good let's give it a try red
bean is so good kind of nutty almost
similar to sweet potato i love it
this one is the hedgehog one this one's
my favorite it's so cute although it's a
little bit harder i must say i have my
dough prepared this is the white dough
the brown dough and some black dough so
have your white dough next to you press
down and gonna press this down to be
much larger than the white one because
this is going to wrap around the white
one it doesn't need to be perfect
totally fine if it looks like this no
problem once you have your taro scoop
we're going to want to wrap it around
three quarters of the way and to make
the taro paste i just added some freshly
steamed taro mixed in some sugar and
some butter and combined it until it was
nice and smooth like this and then i put
it into the fridge to chill for a little
bit because it's just a little easier to
work with when it's colder and thicker
so you can leave a little bit of it
exposed like this and then we're going
to want to round out the bottom because
that's the part that we're going to see
and now i'm just going to drape it over
because we want the edges to stick we're
going to add a little bit of water
around the edge if you're not feeling
the hedgehog you can kind of see from
here how you could go with a lion
instead if your edges are a bit unsmooth
you can apply some water and once you
get it to a place where you like it we
are going to get to making the features
two dots for the eyes
a larger dot for the nose
and then two for the ears
two smaller ones for the little arms and
then two medium sized ones for its
little seats now that the front of the
hedgehog is done we're going to work on
the back side so get your kitchen
scissors i find this part the easiest
when i'm holding it and we're just going
to cut
its little spikes
make
your way around
and we're just gonna make sure we get in
some window spacing
and it's just gonna look like this we're
gonna let these guys rest for 30 minutes
and then we can steam them for nine
minutes you probably know the drill by
now once those nine minutes are done
we're gonna let them cool down again
before we break it open this is what it
looks like on the inside with the taro
paste
it looks really good i want to try this
cheers mmm taro buns are my favorite and
also aren't they so cute
this one is the cat shaped bow with pork
filling once you've gotten your dough
into this position you can go ahead and
put in your pork filling made with
ground pork finely chopped cabbage soy
sauce sesame oil
green onion
salt and pepper and just mix it until
it's well combined we don't need to do
the pleating as long as it's sealed up
it's totally fine and it should look
something like that put it back down
onto the counter and then we can smooth
out the bottom make sure it is nice and
sealed if it's not sealed then when you
steam it all the juices are going to
come out put it onto the parchment
square and let's begin decorating for
the cat we'll need some black dough for
the eyes nose
whiskers two ears it's so cute
i feel so aggressive
we're gonna steam the buns for 10
minutes when i'm working with pork i
like to give it an extra minute just to
make sure it's fully cooked through once
the buns are done steaming and you've
let them rest for another five minutes
or so
we can finally eat them
i love that the cabbage and the filling
keeps it nice and moist it's a very
simple pork filling that you can also
use in dumplings but you can also spice
this up and make it your own this one is
the cow shaped bow with veggie filling
if you want to make it completely vegan
you can sub the milk in the dough with
water so let's grab our white dough and
we are going to fill it with our veggie
filling to make the veggie filling i
added in some finely chopped cabbage
some diced shiitake mushrooms some green
onions some minced ginger some soy sauce
sesame oil and black pepper and mixed it
all until it was well combined you'll
notice that there is no egg added as a
binder so it is a bit crumbly but don't
worry it's fine it's still absolutely
delicious and let's just seal it up just
make sure that it's airtight and try to
avoid air bubbles if you can once it's
all nice and sealed you can throw it
upside down onto the counter
roll it out nice and thin and for the
cow i like to work with the dough while
it's on my hand it's much easier to
design that way and it's time to
decorate our cow let's make our two
horns with a black dough add the two
ears i'm shaping them into teardrops
some pink dough for the nose and back to
the black dough for the eyes and the cow
spots
and then we're gonna poke in the holes
and there you have the cow oh my god i
love these so adorable once you've let
your cows rest for 30 minutes we can go
ahead and do our final steam of the day
i am ready let them steam for nine
minutes and let them rest for another
five with the heat off and then they are
done
look at that they're so cute
and look at the filling on the inside
let's give this a try they're so rich
and i like the veggie filling because
it's very nice and moist if you're not a
fan of mushrooms you can swap it out
with your favorite vegetables all right
guys those are all the battles i have
for today i hope you enjoyed making them
with me and if you end up making any of
these boughs make sure to take a picture
and tag me on instagram so i can see
[Music]
every year during the mid autumn
festival my family gathers around the
table to indulge in moon cakes moon
cakes are like works of art
one of the most popular types of moon
cakes is the one with the salted egg
yolk in the middle covered with a sweet
lotus paste and encased in a golden
dough then finally molded with the most
intricate and beautiful designs we'd cut
them into quarters and we bet on which
slice would have the most yolk and then
we'd fight for it
they're rich sweet
savory and made with lots of hard work
and love
i even remember as a small girl thinking
that they were too beautiful to eat
one year my mom had given me a moon cake
to bring to school to share with my
friends
i remember thinking that i would eat it
alone during recess because i was too
scared to share my culture
i didn't want to share these traditions
that others would find strange
but as i sneakily took it out of my
backpack my friend turned to me
excitedly and told me it was the
prettiest thing they had ever seen she
wanted to try it
my face lit up and we shared the
mooncake and i began to tell her all
about the legend of chang-uh the chinese
goddess of the moon
[Music]
now maybe you've never seen moon cakes
before maybe you're remembering that the
first time you learned about moon cakes
was when you were sitting in front of
the tv watching wendy wu homecoming
warrior on disney channel
either way you're about to see how to
make these beautiful moon cakes and how
they came to be an iconic part of the
mid-autumn festival from the famous
ancient chinese myth
the legend goes that a chinese archer
named ho e shot down nine sons from the
sky
leaving just one
saving the world from being scorched
and after his courageous act he was
given an elixir of immortality from
heaven
hoi's wife chang drank the elixir which
caused her to become so light she
floated all the way to the moon with
nothing but her rabbit companion
some iterations of the story say that
chung drank the elixir as an attempt to
keep it away from haui's wicked
apprentice while houi was out hunting
haui began to prepare a feast each year
on the day when the moon was at its
fullest in honor of his wife who he
missed
hoping to see her shadow on the moon and
this feast included moon cakes
a traditional treat eaten during the
mid-autumn festival even till this day
but not everyone shared moon cakes as a
treat of love and admiration
it was once reported that the treats
became popular during the yuan dynasty
when the cakes were reportedly used as
paywall essentially a vessel to deliver
secret notes to assist han chinese in
overthrowing the mongolian rulers of the
time
the mid-autumn festival is traditionally
celebrated on the 15th day of the eighth
month which is supposedly the night the
moon is at its fullest and brightest
each country celebrates in their own
special ways in vietnam the festival is
considered children's day with
celebrations including paper lantern
fairs and lion dance parades
in southern china many people eat autumn
fruits like pomelos and star fruit as
well as lighting lanterns
certain villages in hong kong keep up
the tradition of fire dragon dancing
throughout narrow alleys in south korea
the festival lasts three days and is
used as a time to sweep ancestors tombs
and wear traditional garb in japan
people eat grilled sticky rice balls
while partaking in moon viewings and in
taiwan people have barbecues and admire
the moon
nowadays you'll see families exchanging
moon cakes of all sorts of flavors the
traditional lotus seed paste with salted
egg yolk red bean
nuts
custard green tea
chocolate and many more families gather
and have a feast with lots of food
fruits and desserts and while everyone
has different ways of celebrating
mid-autumn festival family is always at
the center
the festival is filled with joy and
laughter sharing special traditions
admiring the moon and of course sharing
moon cakes and while some people may
find moon cakes strange or unappetizing
they're always going to be special to me
it was once a food i was too embarrassed
to share because i was ashamed of my
culture
i was ashamed of myself
but not anymore
i love being able to share moon cakes
with my friends and family and telling
them about old chinese legends and the
traditions that come with it i love that
moon cakes remind me to be proud of my
heritage and i love that moon cakes are
little beautiful works of art that you
share with your friends and family you
love so much the most special people in
your life and i hope you get to enjoy
some mooncakes this year
[Music]
hi i'm jasmine and today we're going to
be making an epic cheesy volcano fried
rice it's absolutely delicious packed
with flavor it's savory it's spicy
slightly sweet and there's bacon garlic
and cheese so we can't go wrong with
this dish i've already prepped all the
ingredients so let's start cooking
we're going to start by making the fried
rice i'm adding some chopped bacon to my
pan over medium heat and we're going to
cook it until it's about halfway done
we're gonna let the bacon fat render
smells so good already we can add in our
garlic and our green onions
gotta get every last bit we're just
gonna let that cook for a couple of
minutes so the garlic and the green
onions can soak in the flavor of the
bacon it smells so good i just can't
focus
[Music]
i can't i can't focus when
i can't
i can't talk
and smell this at the same time once it
looks something like this we can go
ahead and make some space in the middle
and throw in our chopped kimchi
now you can drain your kimchi if you'd
like but because i'm aggressively in
love with the intense flavor of
condensed kimchi juice i will not be
draining it so we're going to cook down
the kimchi until it dries up a little
bit and turns from this vibrant dark red
to a little bit of a reddish brown we
want to make sure that it's well reduced
otherwise once we add in the rice and
the sauce it's just going to be one
soggy wet mess also if you're not a huge
kimchi fan you can reduce the amount of
kimchi in here or even just take it out
completely but if you haven't tried
cooked kimchi i really do recommend that
you try it because it tastes so
different from raw kimchi
free facials
so once your kimchi looks something like
this we're ready to add the sauce and to
make the sauce we're just going to add
in two tablespoons of gochujang which is
korean red pepper paste two tablespoons
of mirin which is sweet rice wine one
tablespoon of soy sauce and one
tablespoon of sesame oil and just give
it a good mix just gonna pour it all
over the kimchi bacon garlic and green
onions i mixed all the sauces first in a
different bowl i think it helps break
down the pepper paste better and mixes
in better but you can add it directly to
the pan if you want perfect let's mix
this up
until it's well combined
wow
the smells are immaculate in my
apartment
yum okay this is coming together so
nicely i'm gonna add in two cups of
leftover rice left over okay guys
left over rice you can use fresh if you
want to but then don't get mad at me if
your fried rice is wet and soggy use
leftover rice gonna break up the larger
chunks and just get all of this well
incorporated we're going to cook the
rice for three to four more minutes and
i'm actually going to let the rice crisp
up on the bottom when my best friends
and i made fried rice in college we
would always let the rice crisp up and
then we would fight for that scorched
rice because the texture is just so
so good it's actually a very popular
snack amongst koreans it's called
nurunji and it's literally just scorched
rice it's
so good
all right y'all this looks about done so
we're gonna turn off the heat and we're
going to transfer this into my volcano
shaped bowl and while i'm a thousand
percent positive that every single one
of you has a volcano shaped bowl in the
off chance that you don't have a volcano
shaped bowl you can just use a small to
medium sized bowl as deep as you can
find this is the bowl i'm using i
usually use this for my noodles and it's
actually the perfect volcano shape let's
carefully transfer all of our fried rice
into the bowl and we're gonna press it
down until it's compact
now we're gonna safely flip this onto
our new pan your heat should not be on
yet don't burn yourself i'm actually
gonna put the pan on top of the fried
rice
and we're gonna flip it
okay
give it a little jiggle so it comes out
i'm gonna indent the top a little
careful if you press too hard and too
fast it will break apart oh i'm getting
so excited
why is food so fun
and so good
i'm gonna make a fat crevice over here
so we can get a lot of egg and cheese
lava our volcano looks ready for the egg
and cheese lava let's turn our heat back
on
to medium
and it's time for some action baby i
have four whisked eggs in here and i'm
just gonna pour it over our volcano
oh
my god
ah
it looks so good
cheesy goodness guys gonna top it with
mozzarella
and just pour it all over our eggs
if you love cheese you know i'm not
stopping you from adding more
if you want to go the extra mile
sometimes i like to add sweet corn
and it just oh food heaven
we're gonna cover our pan just until the
eggs cook through and the cheese melts
avoid overcooking your eggs because we
don't want it to be dry and rubbery we
want it to be light and fluffy
all right guys looks about done this is
the cheesy volcano fried rice a
delicious kimchi fried rice surrounded
in an egg and cheese moat topped with
even more cheese this is a good day
[Music]
moment of silence please
hmm
sometimes food just needs
a moment
to shine
wow that's so good of course it's not
too different from your average kimchi
fried rice but making it like this is so
fun
i'm gonna invite my boyfriend to try it
george you want to come try this
sure
whoa that is beautiful i kind of ruined
it i mean it already looks so good the
lava is flowing out you want to try yes
i would love to
good
you did a good job
that's so good
hey guys i'm jasmine and i love
boba you might have seen me over on
bring me trying to finish a gallon of
boba milk tea or trying unique boba
treats in taiwan because for me boba is
just one of those things that can turn a
bad day into a better one so i thought i
would share five delicious and gorgeous
boba recipes with you all so we can
enjoy them together
all right guys we're gonna start by
making the boba first we're making it
from scratch of course if you don't want
to make it from scratch you can buy
pre-made boba from any local asian
grocery store but actually making boba
from scratch is quite easy and is only
three ingredients three not six three so
let's start by adding in our water
and our muscovado sugar and we're gonna
turn that on to a medium-high heat we're
gonna stir this until it dissolves and
comes to a boil it's starting to boil so
i am going to add in a little bit of
tapioca flour you want to mix this in
well because we don't want these clumps
if you find that you're clumping too
much you can add a little bit of water
to make that dissolve just a little bit
easier once it looks something like this
we're going to add in half of our
tapioca mixture so we're just going to
stir this
really vigorously until it forms a super
sticky dough now that you got a super
sticky dough like this we're going to
turn the heat off we're going to add in
the rest of our tapioca flour and once
that forms into a ball we're going to
move over to a new workstation and roll
out the dough i just let our boba dough
cool for a little bit and i'm
transferring it onto this clean counter
and i'm just going to incorporate all
the tapioca flour into the dough if your
dough feels a little dry you can add a
little bit more water if you feel like
your dough is too wet you can add a
little bit more tapioca flour i'm just
going to knead it until it's all
incorporated once your dough is formed
it should look something like this roll
it into a thick little oval like this
like a potato i split it in half and
then we can easily roll both out if it
gets too long you can separate them when
you think it's the right size make it
just a little bit smaller because it
does expand when you cook it and the
boba dough does get harder to roll once
it cools down so if you want you can put
like a warm wet towel over part of the
dough while you're rolling out the other
part alrighty so i have four
thinly rolled boba dough logs and i am
just going to put them together
and i'm going to be cutting them into
small little boba pieces i think a
quarter inch it's also okay that they're
not all uniform so now that we've gotten
them into our little baby pieces we roll
them up into little balls let me show
you a couple hacks on how i make this a
little quicker of a process so of course
you can do it one by one like this and
you have your little boba or sometimes
i'm able to put five on my palm i'll put
my palm over the other and after some
good old rolling you'll have your
delicious boobas uh it didn't work
today's not a good day all right so
after some time rolling you'll be able
to see that they come out like this
perfect and then we throw them into a
bowl with some tapioca flour and make
sure they're well coated so they don't
stick to each other the other hack is
spreading them onto the cutting board or
your counter whatever workspace that you
choose and just go to town
if you occasionally feel lazy in the
kitchen like me then this hack is great
but make sure your dough isn't too cold
or this hack won't work tada look at
that little boba babies i call it boba
but you know um in different parts of
the world they are called something
different boba bubble tea pearls in
taiwan they say tsun tzu which is pearl
now that the water has come to a rolling
boil we're going to add in all of our
boba and we're going to stir it so it
doesn't stick together it's going to
turn a little cloudy just because of
that excess tapioca flour that was
coating it you can mainly leave it
unbothered for the next 20 minutes or so
while the boba's cooking let's make our
brown sugar syrup it's very simple we're
just gonna add in some muscovado sugar
and some water gonna mix it and let it
reduce just a little bit so it's nice
and viscous now we are going to pour it
into this heat resistant glass over here
yes
gorgeous so now that the bowl is done
we're going to drain it and rinse it
with cold water to keep it from cooking
even more and then we're going to give
our boba a brown sugar bath you hear
that
so we're gonna leave our bobas in this
brown sugar syrup bath for about 30
minutes to an hour
just so it can really soak up that
delicious deep flavor of the muscovado
sugar yum
i put this one first because i think
everyone trying boba for the first time
should definitely try the classic boba
milk tea experience the first step for
making a boba melty is to make our teeth
my favorite part is when the tea bag
hits the water and then that heat that
is slowly bubbling up it causes that tea
leaf to just release its gorgeous dark
brown hue and you can see those swirls
in the water and then you take your
spoon that's my favorite part you press
on the tea bag and it just like
explodes with color
so while the tea is cooling down we're
gonna make our milk mixture i personally
love using condensed milk because i
think it gives it a much richer flavor
it makes your boba milk tea
multi-dimensional and i want every
experience with my boba to be
multi-dimensional once you have those
two together you can whisk
until it's combined so this condensed
milk mixture does make your drink even
sweeter especially with the muscovado
sugar bath that the boba is currently in
so if you prefer your drinks to be less
sweet you can just sub it with more
black tea on average when i go to boba
shops i get a 25 or 50 sweet time to
assemble our first drink so we're going
to start by adding in our boba and then
add in some ice and then we're going to
add in our black tea and top it with our
sweetened milk i like to add it slowly
over a spoon to slow down that pour and
really get those swirls you can see that
i'm actually failing here but it's okay
because it's still pretty and delicious
and voila that's our first drink the
classic black milk tea with boba
wow that is so good
all right guys the next drink we're
making is a mango slush with boba it's
absolutely delicious it was one of my
childhood favorites because it's just so
sweet and summery and refreshing it's
super easy take your blender and we're
going to add in some frozen mango chunks
some water and some condensed milk and
just blend away
once we've blended everything together
we can grab a glass and i'm adding in
some boba that we made earlier and of
course topping it with our mango
smoothie look at how beautiful it is i
love it time to drink the mango smoothie
with boba ah this will be a throwback
mmm mango smoothie guys i mean come on
it's so refreshing
the next drink we are going to make is a
strawberry matcha latte let's start by
making our strawberry puree we're gonna
add in half a cup of diced strawberries
and two tablespoons of sugar we're gonna
muddle it with a fork until it's nice
and
juicy you can muddle it to your liking
so if you like chunks in your drink feel
free to leave some chunks now that we
have it muddled we're gonna let it sit
for 10 minutes so while that's sitting
we're gonna go and make our tea we're
gonna add a teaspoon of matcha powder to
a third cup of hot water and whisk it
until bubbles form on the surface if you
don't have a whisk or a matcha whisk
don't worry you can totally just use a
fork
we're gonna add in our boba per the
usual and then we're gonna top it with
our muddled strawberries now put in the
ice after the strawberries this will
help with the layering we're gonna
slowly add in the half and half the last
step for this drink is to add our matcha
again slowly pour it over this drink
this drink is like very anxiety heavy
huh slowly
oh slowly slowly look guys it's so
pretty strawberry matcha latte the
colors are just absolutely gorgeous
if you're trying to impress your friends
this is a drink to make but i have to
mix it i'm sad i have to but you know
it's just the way things are it actually
is still very pretty those chunks of
strawberry are giving it a nice hint of
red cheers
[Music]
it's the perfect blend of matcha and
strawberry it's light creamy and fruity
i got a mouthful of strawberry puree and
i'm in heaven
this is the taro milky with boba it has
a nuttiness to it that the other drinks
don't have so i've already steeped my
green tea and let it come to room
temperature and now i'm going to whisk
my taro powder into the green tea if you
haven't had tar before taro is a root i
would compare it to a sweet potato but
slightly more bland and slightly more
sweet it's very delicious you can also
sub the green tea with water if you're
not looking for a caffeine kick but
trust me the taste with the green tea
just elevates it to a whole other level
let's get to assembling add in our boba
add some ice and then pour the taro tea
into the glass and then slowly add in
our two tablespoons of half and half
again if you want that gorgeous swirl
you can pour it slowly over the back of
a spoon mix it up and it's time to drink
cheers
[Music]
when you are chewing it and the flavor
of the taro milk tea is fusing with the
boba flavor next level guys next level
this is like the big home run because i
think it's the prettiest this is the pt
latte with boba if you don't know what
pt is it's a type of tea derived from
the butterfly pea flower and it has this
beautiful blue color and if you squeeze
a lemon into it it turns
purple look at that a purple tea we're
gonna steep a teaspoon of loose pt
leaves in a cup of hot water for about
five minutes and then we're gonna strain
it and let it come to room temperature
that's essentially it it's time to
assemble and we're going to start by
adding in our boba ice and then pour in
our pt
oh it's so pretty look at that blue i
almost don't want to ruin it it's just
so gorgeous but we are we're gonna add
in a couple tablespoons of half and half
and it will look like you're drinking
the ocean and there you have it the pt
latte with boba it's so gorgeous let's
give it a try
i would say it tastes like a very very
light version of thai tea so if you
enjoy lighter teas this may be for you
there you have it five must try boba
recipes that are delicious unique and
beautiful if you end up making any of
these boba recipes or all of the boba
recipes make sure to tag me on instagram
so i can see it bye
oh yes
[Music]
you